en europe ce message approuvé par donald
trump est une publicité mensongère qui a
été vu cinq cent mille fois mais
facebook a décidé de tracer une ligne
c'est écrit noir sur blanc facebook
exemple les politiciens de notre
programme de vérification des faits
c'est quoi le meilleur le meilleur
équilibre à trouver entre la censure et
puis la liberté d'expression totale
et puis facebook décidé en ce moment
qu'est bayal est du côté de la liberté
d'expression totale ce qui est
absolument problématique également et
des employés de facebook y voit une
menace ils l'ont dit dans une lettre à
leur pdg ce que ses employés le disent
c'est que facebook n'est pas entré de
protéger la liberté d'expression en
faisant ça mais plutôt cible les gens
vulnérables qui n'ont pas toujours les
ressources pour savoir départager le
vrai du faux et mark zuckerberg lui-même
et sur la défensive il a été pressé de
questions au congrès la semaine dernière
je pense que c'est mal de mentir et
c'est mal de faire une publicité
mensongère
mais la réponse n'est pas simple parce
que toute la responsabilité pèse sur
l'entreprise
on est incapable de contrôler ça on est
capable de réglisse autant au niveau des
régulateurs officielle au niveau
politique du gouvernement
alors on se tourne vers la compagnie
pour faire le travail à leur place et
laisse elle est incapable aussi et
peut-être à certains niveaux pour le
désert dire mais dit complètement parce
qu'il pourrait la publicité évidemment
la principale source de revenus par
exemple la page de donald trump acheté
pour plus de 21 millions de dollars de
publicité à facebook depuis un an et
demi twitter qui vient de décider de
bannir toute publicité politique de sa
plateforme justifie sa décision en
disant nous pensons que la portée d'un
message politique doit se mériter pas
s'acheter ici mathieu prost radio canada
montréal